just like his mom Manvi could one day
need a heart transplant with the waiting
list getting longer and a chronic
shortage of donor organs that
life-changing surgery may take a long
time to happen but he says he'd undergo
anything as long as it keeps him alive
including living with a pig's heart it
is freaky but I wouldn't really go so
much risk oh this is a bit weird that's
not right I'd go with more ok what's the
quickest fix what's going to get me
better the quickest what's going to get
me as healthy quickest what's going to
give me the best quality of life that I
can get 40 years ago this week so
Terrance English performed the first
successful heart transplant in the UK
today he feels this procedure is almost
ready for a huge development it's likely
what they will do a pig kidney
transplant into a human within the next
year and if that works then it'll be
used in hot transponster and that'll
make it huge I think two or three years
perhaps transplants are the only
long-term treatment for patients with
terminal heart failure but the lack of
donor numbers fuelled research into
xenotransplantation techniques where
humans would be given organs from
animals there are thousands of
differences between pigs and humans but
there are also many similarities the
makeup of pig's hearts and the way they
function are similar to that of human
hearts in fact Paul Keim hearts are
already used as models for developing
treatments the heart from the pig would
be modified to hinder viruses that could
infect humans through transplant it can
be extremely dangerous to patients the
body's natural immune response is to
reject the organ
questions will be raised about the
ethics of humans living with pigs hearts
there'll also be religious concerns for
some patience but despite the hurdles
this procedure even has the backing from
the British Heart Foundation the
patients are waiting for a transplant or
critically ill and that if it's shown to
work they will jump they will have no
problem about that because they know
it's it's that you know the only option
thousands of people are in need of a
heart transplant and the demand for
organs is on the rise but these
scientific developments show promise
that pigs could save lives around the
world
Inzamam Rashid Sky News